aquí tenemos dos rectángulos idénticos y
lo que quiero hacer es medir el área de
cada uno de estos rectángulos es decir
ver cuánto espacio ocupan en la pantalla
por supuesto cómo son rectángulos
idénticos entonces deben tener
exactamente la misma área pero lo que
vamos a hacer es medir el área de cada
uno de estos rectángulos utilizando una
unidad diferente déjame empezar con esta
unidad de aquí esta unidad que está de
color rosa vamos a pensar que este
cuadrado que este cuadrado tiene lados
que miden un centímetro entonces este
lado de acá mide 1 centímetro y este
lado de acá también mide 1 centímetro un
centímetro como este es un cuadrado y
sus lados miden un centímetro esto lo
que nos da es que el cuadrado tiene área
de un centímetro a centímetro
centímetro que se me quedó bien rara
centímetro cuadrado
cuadrado muy bien entonces vamos a
empezar midiendo el área utilizando esta
unidad
voy a ir pegando cuadraditos para ver
cuántos caben ahí va uno otro más dos
otro por acá 3
otro más 4
otro más 5
vamos por otro 6 la primera fila tiene 6
y vamos ahora con la segunda fila con
este serían 7 con este 8
con este 9
ya casi terminamos 10
once y uno más uno más darían doce
entonces caben 12 de estos centímetros
cuadrados en esta figura y por lo tanto
podemos escribir que el área el área
el área
de aquí arriba que es igual a la de aquí
abajo es de 12 12 centímetros
centímetros
centímetros cuadrados cuadrados para
grados déjame incluso contarlos aquí son
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 muy bien eso
es utilizando esta unidad pero ahora
déjame utilizar esta unidad esta unidad
le voy a llamar un cuadrado eso de
fútbol ffu me lo inventé específicamente
para este vídeo es posible que no lo
escuches por ningún otro lado entonces
el chiste de de esta unidad de acá es
que un fósforo mide el doble de un
centímetro entonces déjame marcar déjame
marcar un fútbol aquí este lado mide 1
y este lado de acá también mide un
futuro le voy a poner un full
vale entonces como este es un flujo y
éste también lo que esto hace es que
este cuadrado
este cuadrado me da un futuro
no tenga de área un futuro
cuadrado
grado
muy bien ahora vamos a utilizar esta
unidad del fútbol cuadrado que me acabo
de inventar para ver cuál es el área de
la figura debe de ser exactamente lo
mismo que el área de arriba vale
entonces voy a copiar el futuro cuadrado
y voy a empezar a pegarlo ahí tenemos un
cuadrado otro más
y cabe uno más muy bien entonces otra
forma de medir el área de este
rectángulo que es el mismo que el
rectángulo de arriba es utilizando
flujos cuadrados y en este caso tenemos
123 fucus cuadrados y por lo tanto el
área el área
de esta figura de aquí abajo es de 3
cuadrados cuadrados
adrados muy bien entonces pues aquí
tenemos dos figuras que tienen
exactamente la misma área pero si
utilizamos diferentes unidades para
medir las puede que nos den diferentes
números vale pero sigue siendo la misma
área las dos figuras ocupan la misma
cantidad de espacio en la pantalla ahora
una pregunta interesante que si quieres
puedes pensar en tu casa es cuántos
centímetros cuadrados son un futuru
cuadrado nos vemos hasta la próxima